hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter 14 of his work leviathan
thomas hobbes introduces what he calls
the
first and second laws of nature and
these are really
foundational for his moral and political
and social
theory what it is that he's advocating
or to
get us out of the state of nature
which is inevitably a state of war in
which our lives are as he
so famously puts it nasty brutish and
short
and really there's there's two parts of
the solution of how to get out of the
state of nature for thomas hobbs
and the laws of nature are a really
central part of it but they are
not on their own enough to
get us there enough to provide us with
the
framework of a functioning society
in which moral norms can not only be
believed in but
acted on and you could say rewarded and
and protected
so let's start by talking about
what a law of nature is
for thomas hobbes so this is a term
that he's not coming up with himself
although his formulation of it is going
to be
rather unique to him it's an idea that's
been around for
for quite a long time not only in the
sense of you know physics and the
natural laws
governing those sorts of things which
are actually coming a little bit later
but the
notion of there being a a law
that is inscribed upon the human heart
or soul and that we can discover
within ourselves that isn't a law just
of one particular community but is
essentially within all of the human race
and then could be you know made explicit
acted upon taught that is something that
goes back
in the western tradition all the way
back to in some sense aristotle
and definitely the stoics and and it
takes a you know a strong root
within the middle ages so by the time
that hobbes is coming on the scene
there's a lot of discussion
of natural law now notice how he frames
it a law of nature
lex naturalis is a precept
or general rule so that's one key thing
there it's a preceptor general rule
found out by reason another key thing
there
by which a man is forbidden to do that
which is destructive of his life
or taketh away the means of preserving
the same
and to admit that by which he thinketh
it may
well be best preserved so
three really important components there
right it is a
general rule a rule tells us what to do
the same thing with a precept
it is discovered by reason so it's not
coming down to us
from god on high it's not something that
has to be in some ancient text it's
something that any old person could by
exercising their faculty of reason come
up with
and presumably should be you know should
come up with in
situations that call for it and then now
notice this
key truncation other forms of natural
law theory will talk about
more than just preserving life and
they'll also talk about preserving more
than just one's own
life but here hob says it's forbidding
people to do that which is destructive
of
their life or what they need
for their life or to admit things to
leave
out things that they need and he says
that
for though um they they that speak on
this subject used to confound
use and lex right and law they ought to
be distinguished right
is the liberty to do or for bear whereas
law
determines and binds to one of them
so that law and rights differ as much as
obligation
and liberty right so he's saying this is
the source of
obligation and it ends up telling us
what we can and can't do so that
put aside let's think about you know
we're getting down to a little bit more
specific
what are these these first general laws
of nature so he tells us that
exercising our reason if we're stuck in
the state of
nature which is war or if we're worried
about falling into that
we can think to ourself about what would
we need in order to get out of that
and so here's his rule every man ought
to
endeavor peace as far as he has hope of
obtaining it
when he cannot obtain it that he may
seek and use
all helps and advantages of warranty so
the first branch of which
rule contains the first and fundamental
law of nature which is
to seek peace and follow it
so that is a central part the second
part of it says
you know uh by all means we can to
defend ourselves so the first
law of nature you know you can unpack it
in different ways
it's essentially saying this but we'll
put aside the defend yourself
part um if you can indeed
come to some sort of arrangement with
other people
where you have a good chance of enjoying
peace
right comfort safety
security you ought to endeavor it now
what does endeavor
mean we usually think of endeavoring
as you know sort of a vague i'm going to
endeavor to do
something and you people often say this
when they're actually not going to do it
right
hobbs for hobbes this is a really basic
orientation of the human being we ought
to seek it we ought to do
what it is that will bring it about we
will desire it
you know appetite is one form of this
and so
we should we should desire and pursue
peace
now we can only do that so much on our
part
and so here's where we get to the second
law of nature
how do i get on the same page with you
well we give up some of our rights
in the state of nature everybody has a
right to do everything else
as hobbs pointed out in the previous
chapter there's really no moral rules
that have to be recognized
there's no right or wrong you just do
whatever you want to now that means if i
want to go and
burn down your house and steal your
chickens and
you know tie you up and throw you down a
well
and let you drown down there or hold you
for ransom or do whatever else i'm gonna
do
that's okay because you can do that to
me too we have this vast amount of
rights to
pretty much anything and it's anything
and as we say anything goes
well we don't really want that that's
not peace that's a horrible state of war
in which we're all unhappy so what
should we do
how do we get out of that we have to be
willing
when others are are so too
he says as far forth as for peace and
defense of
himself he shall think it necessary
to lay down this right to all things and
be contented
with so much liberty against other men
as he would allow
other men against ourselves so there's
you know quite a few
parts to this right be willing
and willing for hobbes doesn't just mean
sort of a vague thing
will is the last deliberation it's what
you actually
do so you have to do this you have to be
willing
when others are willing only to certain
degrees right so far
as for peace and defense of himself he
shall think it necessary so so far as we
reasonably think that we in order to
preserve peace
and in order to protect ourselves will
give up some rights
and will give up the rights for a state
of equal liberty
with others so you know we can start
with okay i won't kill you you won't
kill me cool
right that's nice what about uh
coming in the middle of the night and
tying you up no i won't do that either
and you don't do that either to me and
we could you know expand this to a whole
bunch of things
all right i won't divert the stream
that's running past your property
that you rely on for your your
agriculture
uh to my fields you don't do that to me
either and we can build up an entire set
of i won't do this you won't do this and
hobbs goes on
and he points out that this is the law
of the gospel
whatsoever you require others should do
to you you do to them
right so don't don't do things that you
don't want other people
to do to you and here's where he has
a long discussion about
how do you actually make this work what
are the nuts and bolts
of these laws of nature that
we can think of how do we make them
actual so there's a number of important
distinctions
that he makes he says right is laid
aside by
renouncing it or transferring it to
another
renouncing when we don't care to whom
the benefit thereof redondeth
transferring when we intend the benefit
to some person or other persons
and when we have done this then we're
said to be obliged or bound
not to hinder those to whom such right
is granted and we have
oughts and we have duties and
justice and injustice and in injury
right
so he goes on and he says
the way that we transfer rights is you
know
by declaration or signification by some
voluntary and sufficient sign or signs
that we do this and he's going to go
a little bit uh later and talk about
implicit
uh ways in which we do this but he says
something really important
here for where we're going he says these
signs are words only
or actions only uh
but and the same are bonds by which men
are bound
and obliged bonds that have their
strength not from their own nature
but from fear of some evil consequence
upon
the rupture so we can make all sorts of
promises and agreements and you know
arrangements with each other
but something has to back them up or
these these laws are not going to really
work
so we renounce or transfer our rights
and he talks about doing this
mutually this mutual transferring of
right is that which men
call contract and he's going to talk
about a
social contract this is where we get the
social contract theory
at least in its most explicit early
formulation from there's
other earlier uh discussions of things
like this but hobbes is is you know one
of the people who's
credited as one of the fathers of social
contract theory so we
we transfer these rights mutually you
know i'm i'm going to give
up the right of going in and taking
whatever i want from your pantry you do
the same
to me we transfer these rights or we
renounce these rights right
then he starts talking about covenant
and he uses this term a lot
now a covenant or a pact
is when there's a future orientation of
it
one of the members has done something
has
you know enacted something or given
something up and it's going to have to
do
with the future and so he says
one of the contractors may deliver the
thing contracted for
on his part leave the other to perform
his part at some determinate time after
and in the meantime be trusted then the
contract is called pact or
covenant or both parts may contract now
to perform
hereafter in which cases he that is to
perform in time to come being trusted
his performance is called keeping of
promise or faith and the failing of
performance violation of faith
so we have this entire orientation
towards the future
not just the immediate situation but i
say
okay i'm not only not going to steal
your stuff today
and you're not going to just do that
we'll do that tomorrow
next week and the week after that and
and really
forever now that's important
this future orientation because that's
what allows us to
predict other humans behavior and to
have a sense of security
that we're looking for he also says
something
really interesting at the very end of
this chapter
he tells us that oaths don't add
anything
to this because you've already bound
yourself here we go
an oath taken according to any other
former right than his that sweareth is
in vain and
no oath an oath adds nothing to the
obligation
a covenant if it's lawful binds in the
sight of god without the oath
as much with it if unlawful it bindeth
not at all
even if it be confirmed with an oath so
oaths aren't really that important
he also mentions too that if there's
transferring of right but then it's not
mutual
but one of the parties wants to gain
friendship
service or from you know or from his
friends
uh and hope to gain the reputation of
charity or magnanimity or deliver his
mind from the pain of compassion
or hope and reward of heaven he says
this is not contract but gift free gift
grace
which words signify one and the same
thing so he's putting that aside right
then he also talks about as i mentioned
you can contract
ex by express you know that is
explicitly or by inference so he says
when you do it expressly you say i give
i grant i've given
you know all that sort of language signs
by inference he says are sometimes the
consequence of words sometimes the
consequence of silence
sometimes the consequence of action
sometimes the consequence of forbearing
and so all of these are you know quite
important
now what backs this up
what enforces the contract this is a
really
key point he says words alone
if they be of the time to come of the
future and contain
a bare promise are an insufficient sign
of a free gift and therefore not
obligatory right
and our worry about all of these things
is that who's going to make sure that
people
follow through on these contracts he
says if a covenant be made
where neither the parties perform
presently but trust one another
in the condition of mere nature upon any
reasonable
suspicion it is void so
that means that you can promise anything
you like in the state of nature
but you don't have to follow through on
it there is one exception i do want to
point out that's kind of
kind of funny here he does say that
covenants entered into fear in the
condition of mere nature are obligatory
and he talks about ransoming your life
right somebody
you know says i'm gonna kill you if you
don't pay a ransom okay you you do have
to follow through on that
um but that's that's not really uh that
important
and he tells us that
if there is a common power set over both
people
making the agreement with right and
force sufficient to compel performance
it's not void the one that performs
first has no assurance the other will
perform after because bonds of words are
too
weak to bridle human beings ambitious
avarice anger and other passions without
the fear
of some coercive common power
which in the condition of mere nature we
don't have
so he says in a civil estate where there
is a power set up to constrain those
that would otherwise violate their faith
that fear is no longer reasonable
and so for that cause he which by the
covenant is to perform first is obliged
to do so so in order to make these laws
of nature
actionable we need some sort of
authority figure
who can compel the people who have made
the agreement
to follow through on the agreement and
it's interesting and kind of paradoxical
because
these agreements here are going to be
the basis for
creating that that social contract that
will acknowledge
somebody as sovereign and so you could
say it's kind of a chicken egg thing but
hobbs thinks that you can get past this
you can make agreements
and then these become binding on
everybody
you